hi everyone
this is professor m science and today i
want to talk about
constants of motion in another one of
our videos on rigorous quantum mechanics
as the name says a constant of motion is
a quantity that doesn't change
as the system evolves in time if you've
studied classical mechanics then most
probably you'll have encountered
constants of motion for example
the angular momentum of a classical
particle moving in a central potential
is conserved central forces include
gravity and electrostatic interaction
and one of the consequences of angular
momentum conservation
is that the trajectory of a particle
stays in a plane today we'll explore
what the constant of motion
is in quantum mechanics let's go
you'll probably be familiar with
constant of motion in classical
mechanics
in the classical context constants of
motion are quantities that are conserved
throughout the motion
in quantum mechanics however the
definition is more subtle
we say that an observable a is a
constant of motion
if it obeys two conditions the first
is that it does not explicitly depend on
time so that its time derivative
vanishes and the second
is that it commutes with the hiltonian
and this is it any observable a that
obeys these two conditions is a constant
of motion
in quantum mechanics the first condition
makes perfect sense
the observable that we're considering
should not explicitly depend on time if
it is to be a constant of motion
the second condition may appear less
obvious but we should remember that in
quantum mechanics time evolution is
given by the schrodinger equation
which tells us that the rate of change
of quantum states is governed by the
hamiltonian
from that point of view it sort of makes
sense that the hamiltonian should
feature somewhere in this definition
and in the rest of the video we'll see
how this second condition leads to a
series of properties that together
mean that an observable can indeed be
called a constant of motion
the first property of an observable that
is a constant of motion
is that its expectation value with
respect to any state
is time independent
to see this we need to remember the
expression for the time dependent of the
expectation value
of the general operator q it is given by
two terms
one proportional to the expectation
value of the commutator of q with the
hamiltonian of the system
and the other the expectation value of
the time derivative of q
we'd write this expression in the video
on iron fest theorem so check it out if
you need a refresher
if we now use this expression for an
observable a that is a constant of
motion
we get that the time derivative of the
expectation value of a
is equal to a term proportional to the
expectation value of the commutator of a
with the hamiltonian
plus the expectation value of the time
derivative of the observable
a but by definition of a constant of
motion
a commutes with a hamiltonian so this
term vanishes
and also by definition of a constant of
motion a is time
independent so this derivative also
vanishes
this means that the time derivative of
the expectation value of a constant of
motion
is overall zero
the next important property of a
constant of motion is that we can always
find the common set of eigenstates with
the hamiltonian
this property arises directly from the
fact that the constant of motion
commutes with the hamiltonian
we know from the video on compatible
observables that we can always find the
common set of eigenstates for two
observables that commute
this means that we can write the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
like this
and we can also write the eigenvalue
equation for the observable a like this
in these equations we label the energy
eigenvalues of the hamiltonian by
en and the eigenvalues associated with a
by
ap the eigenstates here and here
are the same for the hamiltonian and for
a because they commute we label this
common eigenstate with the quantum
number n
associated with the energy eigenvalue
and the quantum number p
associated with the a eigenvalue
from the video on the drawinger equation
we know that the eigenstate of the
hamiltonian
are called stationary states this is
because if the state psi of our system
at time t
0 is equal to an eigenstate of the
hamiltonian
then the state of the system at a later
time t is equal to this phase factor
times the same eigen state as a global
phase factor such as this one doesn't
change the predictions of quantum
mechanics
then the eigenstate of the hamiltonian
don't really change in time
and this is the reason why we call them
stationary states
the extra feature we have now is that
this initial state
is also an eigenstate of the operator a
with eigenvalue ap
labeled by this p here looking at the
state at a later time here
we see that it's still given by the c
eigenstate of a
and the usual phase factor that doesn't
change the physics
this means that if the system is in a
stationary state then the state of the
system is
also an eigenstate of a at all times
in turn this means that if we were to
measure a we would always get the same
eigenvalue
ap and for this reason the eigenvalues
of a constant of motion
the ap here are called good quantum
numbers
the final property associated with
constants of motion is that the
probability of measuring a particular
outcome is time
independent let's first write the
eigenvalue equation for the hamiltonian
we're going to assume we have a
conservative system in which the
hamiltonian is time
independent we also consider again the
eigenvalue equation for the constant of
motion
a let's now consider an arbitrary state
psi
at time t0 to study the time evolution
of this state we derived a recipe in the
video in the joiner equation for
conservative systems
the first step of the recipe is to
expand the initial state in the basis
spanned by the eigenstates of the
hamiltonian
as usual the expansion coefficients are
given by this bracket
we can now immediately construct the
state at a different time t
as given by this new expansion
where the expansion coefficients are
related to the original ones by a simple
phase factor
from these expressions we can now
calculate the probability of getting a
particular outcome when we measure a
at these different times the probability
of measuring
ap at time t 0 is equal to the absolute
value squared of the corresponding
expansion coefficient
i'm assuming that the eigenvalue is
non-degenerate but it would be trivial
to extend this discussion to the
degenerate case
the probability of measuring the same
eigenvalue at later time t
is now equal to this
using this expression up here for c and
p at time
t we can rewrite it like this
this phase factor has magnitude 1 so we
end up with this
comparing these two expressions we see
that the probability of getting
ap for a measurement at t 0 is the same
as the probability of getting ap
at a different time t overall this means
that when we measure a physical property
that is a constant of motion
then the probability of getting a
particular eigenvalue is the same
at any time
and that's it but let's recap before we
finish a constant of motion is a
physical quantity whose associated
observable obeys
two conditions the first is that it's
time
independent and the second is that it
commutes with the hamiltonian
from this definition we've then derived
the number of properties
associated with constants of motion we
found that their expectation value is
time
independent we've also found that the
eigenstates of a constant of motion
are time independent and we've also
found that the probability of a
measurement outcome of a physical
property that is a constant of motion
is time independent with these
properties you can now understand why we
call observables that obey these two
relations
constants of motion constants of motion
in quantum mechanics
are very useful because of the time
independence
of expectation values of eigenstates and
of measurement probability outcomes
as a concrete example angular momentum
is a constant of motion
in central potentials which is really
helpful when we try to then understand
the behavior of systems like the
hydrogen atom i hope you liked the video
and please subscribe